this is an interesting way to pass the
time for you or at least it will get
more interesting once we start talking
about football let's get back to carlos
dunlap let's do it on his way to seattle
he wanted out
b.j finney in a seventh-round draft pick
become the compensation for the
cincinnati bengals let's look at this
first from the seahawks angle we
wondered why they weren't in on everson
griffin well now we know they were in on
carlos dunlap and i don't know what
they're getting i was on kjr radio last
night in seattle i do a spot there every
wednesday evening my time late afternoon
their time time change and all that and
they're like well what what are they
getting in this guy is it better with
him or would they have been better off
at the draft pick and be different i
don't know i don't know i don't know i
mean they're the ones who are scouting
the guy they're the ones who are making
the decision that he's still got gas in
the tank the problem is you get a pass
rusher at this stage of his career you
don't know what you're getting chris
yeah not only one way to find out you
put them on the field and you see no
you're right i'm sure they did their due
diligence i mean there's evidence out
there of what he looks like you know
that that's partly what i do you know
when i when i saw the trade happen
yesterday that's what i did i went back
and i said let me start watching some
carlos dunlap plays just to get a look
for him just really study and hone in on
him you know i think they made the right
move here first off seventh round pick
you know you're not going to get that
type of player for carlos dunlap i mean
it's rare i understand it can happen but
they're in the middle of a super bowl
run and i think they look at it and go
wait this year is up for grabs and we're
good and we arguably have the best
player in the game as far as russell
wilson's concerned so let's go for it
you know dunlap fell out of favor in
cincinnati but i'll say this mike just
from what i watched you know he doesn't
play a ton but
it speaks a lot that when it's an
obvious passing down they put him back
in right even though he's falling out of
favor and he does still have some juice
left there's no doubt he's better off
the edge than anybody seattle has i can
say that confidently and you know that's
not a bold statement it's a bar it's a
low bar exactly right but i do think
it'll help their football team in the
run defense and pass rush because i
think he can do either one even though i
know they're a little mad at him the way
he played run defense in cincinnati
it is amazing when you look at his time
in cincinnati he became a full-time
starter in 2013 and he started every
game he played
since then
and he's only missed two games since
then he started 16 games 2014 through
2018 started 14 games last year and he
had nine sacks last year
so you know even though he's into year
number 11 of his career and again yeah
just like with everest and griffin who's
in your number 11. you have to be
concerned about
that cliff yes it goes and goes and then
that's it
straight down right i mean i haven't
heard anything specific about what the
bengals didn't like about dunlap all of
a sudden and why he fell out of favor i
don't know if you have if you have feel
free to let it be known unless it's
something that could get a sued for
defamation but uh yeah wait wait a vet
way to vet these things on the fly but
uh but seriously though
the bengals for whatever reason
didn't want to keep them around yeah for
whatever reason that relationship fell
apart
and they just decided let's take what we
can get and here's the thing apparently
that's the best offer they could get
right yeah bj fitting a lot and a and a
seventh round pick it's not like there
was a clamoring of teams to try to get
carlos dunlap away from the bengals at
this point no well you know there's not
great sex appeal it's not like oh wow
he just pops off the screen at you
because you just look at the amazing
physicality or skills he has that way
but you said it it's nine sacks last
year it's always around eight and a half
nine sacks his whole career and there is
a little more value to that you know he
he he gets around the quarterback a lot
even this year when he's in there hey
look at last week against jack conklin
he pushed jack conklin back a lot he
could collapse the pocket he can get out
of run around the edge he's a big
defensive end which will allow him to
play run defense as well and i think
more or not in cincinnati it just it
seems i don't know any of this inside
info but i've been reading about this
for the last five or six weeks that
there's issues there and it just seems
like they wanted to play some of the
young guys he wasn't cool with that he
didn't want to share split time and all
that and it seemed like it kind of got
worse and worse as they cut you know
time away from them because you know
they have a carl lawson an amani bledsoe
and um
uh missing another name oh
uh uh the the kareem from khalid kareem
from notre dame who plays in there a lot
so i think it's a little bit of knowing
that yeah it's coming to an end for
carlos dunlap let's start playing young
guys he didn't like that i think he was
probably like wait i'm better than them
still
and you know that's caused the issues in
cincinnati
he signed through 2021 he got a salary
next year of 10.25 million and the guy
has been around a while and the bengals
have believed him it's just strange to
see a guy who's been a cornerstone yeah
of the bengals for so long so quickly
fall out of favor and you got plenty of
guys in
cincinnati i've been happy uh-huh gino
atkins not happy aj green i mean you
know he he's not a guy who's going to
come out and say right i'm not happy but
the vibe you get is he's not happy john
ross
wants out
and and you know usually and there's a
point shereen williams made last night
and i wasn't aware of this
that was the first trade made by the
bengals in season
since carson palmer in 2011. and before
that in-season trade was like 1985 or
something like that this isn't something
the bengals do
and uh yeah they did it and we're right
about at the point where if you want the
guy available week nine you need to do
it now let's look at it though from
cincinnati's perspective we know seattle
needed the pass rush they got the pass
rush at least some pass rush help we'll
see whether or not he is worthy of the
investment made from the bengals
perspective is this a sign of a new way
of doing business i mean at a time when
so many guys are unhappy
at that same time you get this vibe that
they're doing things differently in the
front office it's hard to reconcile the
two because you've got a locker room
with disgruntled guys but you do have
maybe a different vibe from the
perspective of how the team is being
managed well yeah it does it seems like
maybe it's gonna be a hair more
aggressive they seemed a little bit more
aggressive in the off season this year
as far as free agents and things like
that so
maybe this is a new wave i i mean again
i think the time is now for cincinnati
to make some moves you've heard you know
i know we're both in agreement there
i've been saying that you know yeah it
does seem like they're trying to kind of
flip their team over
and aj green where he's at in his part
of his career i don't know why they
wouldn't be calling teams and seeing
what's going on there start acquiring
assets you've got a little core
of good things around joe burrow already
you do you got some good young receivers
tight ends okay we know there's a few
young offensive linemen
you got joe mixon you know there's some
young talented guys in the secondary and
some decent young defensive lineman to
go along with it too so i mean i i would
understand them somewhat having a little
bit of a fire sale at least testing the
temperature of the water out there with
some of their players to go well maybe
we can continue to build something and
more of a young nucleus around joe
burrow it would make sense to me
well and and and that's really the key
i i don't want to get our friends in
cincinnati upset here but i really do
feel like joe burrow deserves better
than what he's currently dealing with
there should be excitement right now
with the team there shouldn't be unhappy
members of the organization there should
be people who are saying we've got
this young clear-cut franchise
quarterback
let's let's view the glass as half full
and let's move forward but the reality
in football is everybody's got their own
individual situation and it just seems
glaring when multiple guys at the same
time on the same team
aren't happy and it's odd to see that at
a time when it feels like it should be
morning in cincinnati not this
sense of
it's all falling apart and guys want out
that's what i can't reconcile chris well
i i i get that um i i still think you
know maybe that's more of a feeling in
cincinnati i hope they can overcome it
and be a little bit more at least like i
am and like you are i mean nationally i
think people are excited about
cincinnati
joe burrow i mean what he's doing i mean
again i don't care that they lost the
other day joe burrow was phenomenal in
that football game i mean the the game
and the team is it's about joe burrow
already i mean they just go damn joe
drop back 45 times you got to throw for
404 touchdowns and maybe we can win i
mean that's really how they're playing i
mean that and that just says what he is
but i think you have a faction of guys
who are part of that old regime right
mike who are just they sense it's kind
of a new era and they're stuck in
between guys like aj green and geno
atkins and john ross who probably just
wants a new start all together but you
know i think those guys see it like hey
my time might be coming to the end here
you guys are rebuilding something new
here let me get out of town and maybe
you know get on a shot get on a part of
a team that has a chance to be a winner
here in the next year or two and do
something like that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports